[Music]
for example you know cat videos are so
popular right now oh this coffee table
book didn't sell it's called cats that
don't want to be on the Internet
these cats want their privacy look at
this one this one over here down here is
a real douchebag look at this one I love
this book right here it's because people
like famous celebrity you know anything
with celebrities sure this is famous
people doing handstands in pools that's
Taylor Swift that is her sure of course
you can tell it's her because of that
right there yeah there's a Christian
Bale right there and then look down here
it is Danny DeVito
[Applause]
[Music]
submission check on her check on him
soon here's a coffee table book I can
see why this one didn't sell it's kind
of you know it's called who the hell
ordered that there's a guy right there
the cover is one lobster ravioli right
there he clearly didn't order it we did
yeah there's lamb kabob part of that row
that on then check out this guy
one all-day lift ticket and I think
that's the actor who played the guy in
the audience who is too hot I think yeah
look let's see there he is yeah that's
called lazy staff
just use the same guy no one will notice
we don't have a very deep bench we don't
have a deep bench here at all all right
look at this one right here cock-block
roosters this rooster we're just
watching TV I don't know I can't right
talk to him a lot of NFL scandals in the
news oh yeah so look at this one this is
a coffee table book of Arena Football
League scandals not as big scandals
right here here's one right here
switching the price tag on a pair of
flip-flop Oh refusing to separate
recyclables
that's another vial it says a metal
paper right there yeah and then
overcharging it is night job at the A&P
deli later demin when you look for this
tonight
on the broadcast version of the show you
will not see it it will not be there we
might not have a deep bench but we have
good quality control yeah sword cutting
what was the one before it
I don't know cock-block Brewster yeah
yeah [ __ ] lock rooster
and now the next one
this religion
this one's called slightly creepy food
truck puns okay yeah look at this one
right here this truck says me so horny
kinda creepy kind of creepy
this one's creepy look it's no means no
key that's real creepy that's real and
then look down here this is the
creepiest one statutory crane dad look
at this frat party masterpieces right
here a guy passes out these are real
masterpiece Wow piss pens
usually it's just a magic marker and
rice is airbrushing on yeah this peope
these are people who's got friends that
are really is the Sistine Chapel right
there
[Applause]
in front Lee this one has a complicated
title but it's interesting it's called
REO wasg os Republican elected officials
who were surprisingly good at oral sex
there's senator mitch motorboated
McConnell Senator Lindsey the dapper
laughter Graham
oh man senator Roger Chowhound wicker
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you